ici comme ailleurs les marques de
commerce anglophones se multiplient
l'office québécois de la langue
française voulait forcer ces entreprises
a ajouté un descriptif en français des
commerces ont contesté cette exigence et
les tribunaux leur ont donné raison
québec a décidé de ne pas en appeler de
cette décision le gouvernement va plutôt
modifier un règlement de la loi 101
la charte de la langue française pour
préciser cette obligation nous croyons
qu'il est possible d'assurer la
visibilité du français sans altérer la
marque d'origine
concrètement ça veut dire que les noms
d'entreprises en anglais vont demeurer
moi j'ai déjà indiqué qu'ils étaient pas
question de faire traduire les marques
de commerce par exemple canadienne
ailleurs ne deviendrait pas pu me
canadien mais le gouvernement exigerait
une forme de descriptifs en français
avec la marque de commerce d'un
générique c'est habituellement un mot
qui précède la marque de commerce
les cafés starbucks un slogan ça peut
être par exemple
starbucks le meilleur café au québec et
slogans en dessous impossible d'aller
plus loin a indiqué baek les marques de
commerce bénéficie d'une protection
juridique y aura modifications
réglementaires
alors nous allons faire le travail qu'il
faut pour bien balisé des modifications
réglementaires qui ne touche que
l'affichage extérieur
certains pensent qu'on doit aussi
imposer ses règles
à l'intérieur des commerces pourquoi pas
exigé que les noms de marques de
commerce soit sur le territoire du
québec accompagné en tout temps du
générique ou du descriptif
le conseil canadien du commerce de
détail et se disent satisfaits de cette
décision de protéger les marques de
commerce mais il reste à préciser
plusieurs éléments comme par exemple les
sanctions
beaucoup de travail puisque le
gouvernement soit instauré les
changements début 2007 les coûts seront
importants pour les entreprises et
québec reconnaît qu'on pourrait devoir
leur verser une compensation financière
pour qu'elles ajoutent une touche de
français à leur marque de commerce ici
david gêne-t-il radio canada québec